what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I've been thinking about this
for the last few days or so and and
after having seen Deadpool - I feel like
they're gonna bring Hope Summers in in
Deadpool three x-force whatever you want
to call it and if they do hope is gonna
decimate all like like do is all who's
gonna be a bloodbath like it's it's man
do Hope Summers is so overpowered like
it's not even funny like like the
daughter of cable she's not really even
the daughter of cable I mean they could
do that in the Deadpool movie that's
fine if you guys know what I'm talking
about that's fine if you don't ask
whatever but like the movie outperformed
infinity Wars so I figure people who are
gonna see it like if idiots like the
people who really really don't want to
have it spoiled they would have seen it
by now so like like I'm looking at this
and I'm just like dude hopes summer I
mean it's crazy like it's like okay okay
so so it's like 2004 right like like why
the clock back alright wanna clock back
14 years its 2004 and like joke Asada's
editor-in-chief at Marvel right like he
came on in early 2000s really in like
around 2000 2001 something like that and
he's like okay so like everything you
guys have been doing for like the last
20 years is bad because you guys almost
bankrupted the entirety of your company
because of all the stuff you were doing
so like what we're gonna do is we're
gonna not do that stuff and then we're
gonna do new stuff so that we don't
destroy the entirety of Marvel Comics
because Disney didn't own Marvel at that
point Marvel was just free-floating it
was like if Marvel lost and funnelin
bankrupt like there'd be nothing that's
why they sold off the movie rights like
they were barely trying to stay afloat
and so casada comes in this is after Ike
Perlmutter and toy biz buyout Marvel and
they start like financing it so they're
like okay we're gonna dump money into
Marvel and we're gonna get you guys a
float Joe Quesada comes in and he takes
care of the comic books ad right like
you got Kevin Feige and avi arad and all
those guys who were taking care of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe side because
that because the MCU was like six or
seven years in the making
it didn't just pop out like a year
before Iron Man came out it been around
for a little while but like casada is
like okay so like we need to basically
just rework the entirety of Marvel
Comics like we're just gonna basically
start over again
so we so he looks around he says stuff
like okay the Avengers as they exist now
are born get rid of them so like we have
Avengers disassembled we're like The
Avengers breakup made to span and then
you get new Avengers which is like
Spider Man Wolverine Iron Man Captain
America basically the cool characters
that the characters don't like you know
and love
and it would be fun to see him on an
Avengers team so the other thing that
joke aside
did is he looked around he said okay so
like there's too many mutants right now
like there's way too many meetings like
we have we have we have characters like
unas the untouchable who's actually the
crappiest mutant ever Ernest the
untouchable was a guy who had the
ability to create a force field around
himself and I cannot remember exactly
what happened but somehow he lost
control of his powers and suffocated
inside of his own force field crappiest
hero ever like he was really hero he was
a villain crappiest meaning ever like
Otis the untouchable I mean I guess he
was untouchable like he was untouchable
by oxygen-oxygen couldn't touch he was a
terror was a really really crappy guy
okay so uh so casada sits down and says
like we have to rework the entirety of
Marvel comic try like we have to rework
this whole thing so like we're gonna
reduce the mutant population so you have
an event called House of M which
actually follows Avengers disassembled
well the Scarlet Witch goes crazy right
like like Scarlet Witch goes nuts and
she's convinced that like The Avengers
have hidden her children from her they
kind of exist they kind of don't
whatever but uh but anyway like she goes
on a warpath right like at this point
she is she's like channeling the power
of C'thun who's like this ancient elder
god from like earth and the Marvel
Comics and it's just got like these
crazy crazy powers he has Chaos magic
which technically shouldn't exist like
Doctor Strange is like there's no such
thing as Chaos magic it's like yeah but
there is though cuz Scarlet Witch is
using it right now so like like it gets
kind of crazy when you're getting to
that whole thing and so so like like she
just starts going berserk
right like like she uses her powers to
like make Tony Stark appear drunk in
front of the United Nations like support
for Stark Industries plummet like
shareholders start backing now and Tony
Stark's like hey guys I can't back the
Avengers anymore sorry about your luck
piece and like bails so he takes off so
Captain America is like well if we don't
have no money then we ain't got no game
so like they break up they're like well
I mean you know how cuz if the money
ain't there then I guess that's just the
way I go so they split up right like so
the Avengers the avengers disband and
then like like Charles Xavier at the
request of magneto goes to the mutant
island of Genosha which used to be a
place where mutants hung out until until
Cassandra Nova sent like simp sentinels
there and wiped out 16 million like all
16 million mutants who live there where
the exception of like a handful like
like two mutants survives like one was
Emma Frost whose second power of like
turning into diamond for manifested and
I think
was Magneto but like you do it was
insane like they're just walking through
the island just like blasting everything
they see and it's just like damn look
it's absolute massacre so so like so so
what you have is you you have Charles
Xavier working on trying to fix the mind
a Scarlet Witch because it's so broken
and fractured well then like like like a
whole like crazy stuff starts happening
Xavier calls like all the Avengers and
all the like everyone who's ever been an
x-man calls them all to Genosha and he's
like so like we have to we have to kill
Scarlet Witch and they're like what yes
kill you like we have to kill Scarlet
Witch they're like wait like what do you
mean we have to kill Scarlet Witch like
that's not okay bro and Xavier is like I
know that man like I know it's not okay
to just run around killing folks like
everybody's kind of debating on whether
or not they should and so then like like
Xavier vanishes out of thin air right
like people like where the hell is
Xavier I just just disappears like a
fart in the wind he's just gone and so
people are just like what the hell is
going on it's like we got to go find
Charles Xavier
so they all start hunting for Xavier and
one by one they all start vanishing they
all start disappearing all right like
spider-man's the last one left and he's
like ah guys like my spider sense is not
tingling at all so I have no idea what
the hell's happenin and then they're
just like a bright light and he's gone
everybody wakes up in the house of M
which is basically this this universe
where everybody gets everything they
want and so you end up finding out - the
Scarlet Witch was the one who did that
and it's like dude it's like the most
badass scene when they all find out he's
like do it all dude is so beast this is
why this needs to be a movie right so
like everybody thinks magneto is the one
that got Scarlet Witch to do this
because she's the daughter of magneto
and like so it's you know quicksilver's
a son of magneto well then you end up
finding out it was Quicksilver who got
Scarlet Witch to do it that crooks ever
went to Scarlet Witch and was like you
can fix everything and you can make
everything okay if she's like okay and
then like uses her powers and and goes
nuts and so like you're like like
magneto finds out what Quicksilver did
it's like the most badass scene ever
magneto comes and he's like what have
you done in my name boy and like freaks
out on him like kills him like a Duke
magneto kills cars like he kills
Quicksilver like like takes this giant
like thing and just since it like flying
like just start smashing him like it
just like it's like the most insane
thing ever and so like like like Scarlet
Witch freaks out she's a are you killed
Quicksilver like resurrection from the
dead because whatever and so like like
Quicksilver comes back to life
and like like like Doctor Strange is
like you know doing his little hand
gesture things you know he's like
Scarlet Witch you have to fix things you
have to set them back and so Scarlet
Witch is like okay fine and then right
before she said like do do like right
before she sets things back she says no
more mutants and so like everything goes
back to normal but ninety eight percent
of the mutant population of lost their
powers and it's just like holy hell dude
is pandemonium right like after that
came a story called decimation and it's
just it's crazy like like Emma Frost
wakes up and in the x-men mansion and
kids are like screaming you know it's
like it's like it's like what's-his-name
from The Godfather when he wakes up with
a horse's head miss bet he's just like
oh it's like they're it's like the
craziest thing so kids are freaking out
in panic and Wolverine wakes up and all
of his memories are back and it's just
like dude he goes on a wall dude after
Wolverines memories come back he's like
okay so like I have a list here of all
the people who have screwed me over and
like they're all gonna die and like duty
he goes and he goes I like this crazy
warpath it's like the coolest thing ever
like shield can't stop him
they're like like shields always like
three steps behind that like yeah so we
found out where Wolverine was going he's
like where's he going the place he just
left like this it's the craziest thing
like like it's it's so awesome like
where do you have that whole thing going
on so anyway like 90% of the mutant
population loses their powers right and
like Xavier is gone that he comes back
and like Cyclops is like you can't
believe the x-men team anymore because
you're old and like I'm gonna leave the
x-men team now old man and so like like
Cyclops is running the whole show
all right well then you have this whole
Fame it goes on where like like their
wits they're using cerebro or something
like that like Xavier or somebody using
it to try to detect more mutant signals
and he's just like you know starts
freaking out because there's like this
energy like this mutant that's been born
and just like just it's like it's like
it just just blows up the Richter scale
of like the like the mutant detection
you know cerebro and Xavier is like go
find that kid now like who that kid is
would go find that kid so everybody
takes off to Anchorage Alaska right like
like the x-men I'll take off they're
like okay let's go for him that's good
so they all take off to Anchorage Alaska
right they get there and it's just like
a warzone right like everything in
Anchorage Alaska is just like like torn
to pieces like it's all on fire and
burning and there's like purifiers there
and there's like Marauder
there and the expert on like we
literally land here and it's like it's
like dude it's like landing in Eastern
Europe during World War two like it's
it's it's insane
and so like like what you end a fine and
of course the purifiers are basically
this group that thinks God wants them to
kill humans and do their their hardcore
do their hardcore they were led by
William Stryker one man William Stryker
Morgan Stryker sucked in the x-men
movies he's like one of the greatest
villains ever in the history of Marvel
in Fox's defense though if they had
released an x-men movie in the United
States where you have like a crazy
evangelical guy who thinks God wants
them to kill mutants who the Christians
would start freaking out and then you
have the Marauders who were the the the
people who are ran by Nathaniel Essex
mr. sinister who just kind of carry out
his bidding the roster changes and my
gambit was part of the Marauders in that
point in time because whatever Marvel
had no idea what to do with this
character so they're like just shuffle
him back off to the Marauders again just
just let him back off to the Marauder so
like he goes back over there it's like
the ex and they're looking around and
they're like what the heck but like they
can't find the baby anywhere come to
find out when Cyclops took over the
x-men he was becoming more and more
extreme and militant and so like so he
will reappear some the future and like
takes the baby and disappears into the
timestream
right and so it's just like - -
everything's going nuts is actually
going Iraq that's so like like cables
hopping around eventually the Marauders
catch up with and they kidnapped a baby
Xavier and his cable contacts Xavier and
it's like hey man you got to help me out
so like the x-men go they fight the
Marauders cable gets the baby like
Xavier gives maybe the cable and says
jump into the timestream like get out of
here because like this babies the mutant
Messiah and it'll like bring RVing our
mutant population back and so so so
cable takes the baby and jumps into the
timestream right well then you end up
finding out that this kid hopes Summers
is gonna grow up and there's gonna be
two possible futures one where it
becomes a messiah and another one where
becomes like just like this insane just
like just like an insane insane killer
what happens is you have something
called the six-second war and in six
seconds Hope Summers like annihilates a
million humans and like familiar it
basically kicks off Days of Future past
now the difference is that in in that
future which is actually the future that
belongs to a guy named Lucas bishop what
is up happening because humans a mutants
band together and something called the
Somers rebellion and what that basically
leads to is humans of mutants throat
like casting off the signals and then
have the Xavier security enforces which
is basically a mutant police force
designed to police mutants that's named
after Charles Xavier kind of like that
futures version of the x-men but not
really and then and then as crazy stuff
like Trevor Fitzroy jumps back in the
past and tries to screw things up it
turns in the 1990s comics and it gets
bonkers I always thought Trevor Fitzroy
was kind of cool he could create portals
and then bantam had to close them it was
it was kind of crazy when you get into
that whole thing but still like it's
it's wild because Hope Summers is just
like this ridiculously overpowered
character dude she is so o P Hope
Summers has the power to copy the powers
of other people and there's no limit
there's no limit to the powers that she
can copy she can infinitely I think
protege but the difference between like
Hope Summers and protege is like Hope
Summers never became equal to like The
Living Tribunal and tried to like
destroy everything but it's just it's
it's crazy like it's absolutely bonkers
uh but nonetheless like like dude if
okay let me talk man let me tell you
something you'd have Hope Summers like
let's say Hope Summers shows up right
like she's like a full grown woman and
Hope Summers shows up because she's not
really the daughter of cable she's kind
of like the adopted daughter or whatever
like she shows up and she was like oh
man like things are worse now because of
whatever happened in Deadpool - so like
she shows up as like a villain right man
let me tell you something do this man it
do the x-men and an extra man they will
not be prepared there's there's no way
they can state like not a chance there's
no way the x-men and x-force could
possibly stand a chance against Hope
Summers
no way because she would basically just
duplicate everybody's powers right like
she'd be like okay I have the telepathy
of Charles Xavier and I've got the
healing factor of Deadpool and I've got
the power of this person - the power of
that person I've got the optic viens of
Cyclops and the shape-shifting ability
of mystique and like the ability to just
kind of jump around like beasts and I
can do whatever ro can do in any
whichever one of the movie she happens
to be in and like I can I can basically
do everything like I am the Swiss Army
knife of the mutant world and like
you're all gonna die done and like
that's it like that there's there's no
there's no fight there there's no
conflict there now inevitably Fox will
probably find a way to screw it up so I
mean that's that's Fox's mo right like
Fox is like lists like let's take this
thing and then the the overarching goal
with this thing is to screw it up
anything that's not Deadpool
have to screw it up because like that's
what we do so like fox will inevitably
mess it up but man if they don't do if
they don't man do hope summers won't do
sure sure she'll
decimate off the only way the only way I
think they could possibly introduce
someone who could overcome Hope Summers
might and this is a might could possibly
be strife like the evil clone of cable
that's the only way I could possibly see
that happening and even then there's no
guarantee like even then there's no
absolute guarantee that would happen
Strife's powerful he can just shut off
people's powers he's powerful but like
he's he's I don't know man like Hope
Summers like at full power channeling
all the abilities of the x-men into
herself not a no no man like it would be
it would be insane like it would be
bonkers but I don't know I mean this is
just just this is just my theory here
bringing in Hope Summers a man that bets
that's how you reboot the Deadpool
universe that's what that is
like man you guys thought like Stannis
or the Infinity Gauntlet powerful it's
powerful like in the Marvel Universe
it's powerful but like in the in the
Deadpool movies Hope Summers was like
all the powers of anyone she happens to
come across like anyone who's whose
powers she seems like she sees use not
only that necessarily that she's a
vessel for the Phoenix force that is a
hey guys we're gonna reboot the entirety
of like the Deadpool series so we can
integrate into the MCU
and we're gonna do that by bringing in
hope but again I don't know I mean like
like even like strife with extinction
I'm not extinction strife with
executioner song could probably do it
too
like dude strut man strife is so Opie
you're that guy who strife is uh is a
wrecking machine like it is it is nuts
how powerful that guy's the dude shut
off the powers of Jean Grey just shut
him off he's like and you're done like
you are now a regular person so go do
your regular people things go grocery
shopping and go binge watch stuff on
Netflix you know and watch the view in
the morning because you're probably the
only one like I mean this it's a matter
in mind it'd be insane I'm just saying
stuff like this gets me so excited I'm
just saying because it's like I love
seeing crazy displays of power right
like I love seeing insane displays of
power they would it would be it'd be
awesome to see like it would it would be
it'd be insane oh and then I did like
imagine hope some reason like in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe no come on now
come on now man like it would be it
man who would be a be a sight to behold
like it would be it would be amazing to
see anyway guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come let's explain make sure
you guys at the set button to become
part of the rock or if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]